et
[Musique]
c'était il ya très très très longtemps
en ce temps là un beau matin le dernier
shadoks quitte à la terre et repartir là
d'où ils étaient venus
c'est à dire assez loin ce qu'il arriva
ensuite ma foi nous n'en savons bien les
manuscrits shadoks authentique en effet
s'arrête là et nous sommes bien obligés
de nous arrêter aussi mais nous avons
quand même pu à travers le temps et
l'espace entrer en contact avec notre
correspondant permanent sur la planète
shadoks auxquelles nous allons poser
quelques questions si vous le voulez
bien
monsieur chat d'oc vous m'entendez c'est
formidablement monsieur chat d'oc est ce
que vous êtes aussi idiots qu'on le dit
mais pourquoi un brin mais combien de
temps le resterez vous et bien voilà qui
est parfait et j'en suis bien contente
vous comment obama demandant qu'à et que
pensez-vous de la terre oui avec s
écouler a oui
vers moi mais c'est pas exactement ce
que vous m'aviez dit tout à l'heure un
[Musique]
oui oui 1 1
vous avez aussi vous beaucoup de malades
[Musique]
c'est vraiment passionnant tout ça mais
nous risquons de déborder il faut
courage où elle entraîne si vous le
voulez bien nous reprendrons cet
intéressant entretien demain
[Musique]